foreign
live from the headquarters of at Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing healthy
relationships I am Rachel Cruz Ramsay
personality hosting this hour with my
good friend and fella Ramsey personality
Dr John deloney and we are answering
your questions and it's a free call
anywhere in the country at triple eight
eight two five five two two five so
starting us off this hour is Sarah and
Charlotte North Carolina hey Sarah
welcome to the show
hello how are you we are doing great
thanks for calling how can we help
okay so I um we have a really old family
car
um that probably doesn't have a whole
lot of time left and we're also trying
to save up for baby step three
and I feel like we have to do both at
once because our emergency fund is
really small and our car is really old
yeah so
um my question is number one is that a
good idea should I be doing them
together or should I break them up into
a separate goals and like what's a
reasonable timeline to accomplish both
of them sure uh well how much do you
guys make a year
about 1 30. okay
and for this car that may be leaving you
soon uh how much do you think if you
Kelly Blue booked it what would you what
would you get it for
oh my goodness I don't even think I
could get a thousand dollars for it okay
yeah what makes you think it's dying are
you making 130 Grand and you're
embarrassed or what makes you think it's
it doesn't have much time left
um well it's it's part of its held
together with Dr
um and the hatch won't open and the two
side doors we have to like finagle and
push them really hard my kids have to
like do tricks to get them to close
um I mean I can go on I mean it still it
runs and we can get from place to place
yeah yeah but and it's like 250 000
miles on it
um and so I haven't wanted to get rid of
it because it still works and I don't
have the money to buy a new car and I
don't want to borrow money so yeah yeah
so we don't have a lot in savings so
that's kind of where
I I work um I don't work outside the
home I stay at home with my kids
so it's just one income
um
so
we can only save up so fast sure so how
much you guys saving a month for towards
the emergency fund and the car
okay for about five months and then did
you get five thousand dollars
yeah we do and we have
for a new car okay
yeah and then we have um
in like 1900 in our emergency fund so
that's really low yep yep what's y'all's
goal you know what what amount for are
you guys shooting for for your emergency
fund
um well three months for us would be
about fourteen hundred dollars minimum
okay like all just just bills and food
we have um five kids fourteen thousand
or fourteen hundred
oh 14 000 for three months of expenses
okay all right you said 1400 I was like
man your kids eat way less than my kids
no no no no no no no five kids yeah yeah
yeah and I homeschool so I don't bring
in any money even though I work all the
time sure yeah yeah yeah okay well
here's the deal Sarah I mean your car we
we talk about the four walls food
shelter utilities Transportation
transportation is is a to a degree a
need right especially for one car for
one person to leave the home earn money
and come back
um but there are a lot of families you
know I'm not suggesting this but just
say it out loud people do the one car
family a lot I mean that that's a
reality as they're in this process
there's always four or five couples
somebody's dropping somebody off here at
the office because they're trying to get
out of debt yeah yeah we see that they
drop them off and they go back home they
drop them off and they go to their work
right almost I always laugh like oh
thanks Mom but also good for you all man
thank you for you all so that's right
yeah we're making this out yeah for sure
so but what I would say Sarah is yeah I
mean at this point I would keep sticking
it out a few more months with this car
and until the and I don't know cars
drawn you probably could talk more into
this but I'm like until like the engine
until the thing actually breaks and it
won't turn on I know cosmetically it's
super frustrating with the doors and the
duct tape but I'll tell you Sarah when I
grew up and I remember my dad had an old
Lincoln car after they went bankrupt and
all that and I'm picking me up from
school on certain days and the fabric of
the roof of the car was was was loose I
remember that and it would like and it
would and it would say and we would push
our hands up like in the first grade to
like hold it because it would just like
go on us and the air conditioning didn't
work so it was all sweaty it was just
gross right so all that to say
cosmetically I know it's frustrating and
the hatch won't open like I'm I hear you
I hear you Sarah and if I could deliver
you a new Escalade right now I would
like I I know it's not fun but it's
running and that's and that mindset is
kind of where you have to be and then
when it does burnt out and it's gonna
cost more to fix than what it's worth
and you get into that whole debacle for
me that that's where I would pull out of
the emergency fund and I would say I'm
going to start I'm going to I'm going to
earmark five thousand dollars for an
emergency fund or you have almost two
thousand so so I would if I were using I
would say we have seven thousand dollars
in our emergency fund we're gonna keep
saving and saving and savings and we're
going to work towards this 14 and if
something were to happen in the middle
of we've got it we have the cash then to
pull it out if we need to and to say
okay we have to we have to buy another
crappy car for the season of life but
we're going to so it's not going to
you're not going to drain your whole
account you still want money in there
for a small emergency fund but you can
use that cash so I think some people
maybe this is just me personally I know
you know George Campbell may have a
different opinion on this because some
people love to have the but when you're
right now where you are with the state
of your car the emergency fund I would
just feel safer to think okay you know
we have six thousand dollars seven
thousand dollars in savings we're we're
going to continue to stay gazelle
intents and keep putting cash in and
then if we read that reach that fourteen
thousand
and the car still hasn't died then I'm
going to go separate and I'm going to
say okay before I go and throw a bunch
of money at retirement I'm probably
going to save up another five on the
side that's actually what I do I would
hold off on retirement for just a few
more months and this is where I think
families
um I know we're pretty dogmatic about
the baby steps but I also think uh a
husband and wife team can sit there like
and agree on a Sprint and say Hey you
make 130 Grand husband I'm staying home
with with 111 kids here
would you be willing to for four months
deliver pizzas two in the evening or
whatever do Uber Eats and I know you're
exhausted but we could Sprint through
this thing four months right for four
months and then we can go get ourselves
a car that works and so I like what I
love Rachel's idea about let's stack
this thing up if your car happens to
just die
you've got you'll have fourteen thousand
dollars to buy a new car with or ten
thousand dollars and you'll have four
thousand dollars in the emergency fund
but man okay just stopping I try to do
two things at once is almost impossible
and yeah that's what we're finding yeah
it's just not worth it I put it all in
one big savings label the emergency fund
and if something happens
you know because again most of what you
described most of it was cosmetic
um yeah but yeah right it was and it's
frustrating I get it but let me say this
too you can you have this moment where
you and you're probably already doing
this but you can bring your kids Along
on this debt-free ride you can give them
a ringside seat to a mom who is making
sacrifices and so when they get in the
car they're like Mom the door won't open
you can say out loud and we don't owe
anybody any money figure it out and we
can all laugh and smile but when they're
when when you're older and they're older
they'll tell the story of the time mom
didn't give up and that's that's a it
feels like you're sacrificing you're not
you're teaching them lifelong lessons
you guys are doing great Sarah keep it
up this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsay show I am at
Rachel Cruz hosting it this hour with Dr
John deloney and we're answering your
questions when it comes to life to money
everything so AAA
825-5225 it's a free call anywhere in
the country up next we have Carly and
Fargo
North Dakota hey Carly welcome to the
show
hi hello thanks for having me absolutely
thanks for calling how can we help
um so I just have a question about me
and my husband we are buying or hoping
to buy my parents house and I was just
wondering if we are ready to do that all
right is your family ready for that
I don't know so we would be living with
them too in the transition of everything
so you're gonna buy their house and
they're gonna keep living in it
yeah for a little bit and then they are
building and moving no no they're not
they're gonna stay with you forever oh
stop Josh
no they're not okay Carly so
um what do you how much is how much is
the house how much are you buying it for
000 okay and what's your current home
when you sell it what will you have what
will you walk away with
we are going to walk away with around 91
with everything
um
after we pay our current loan okay yep
okay so roughly 160 alone you'll take
out
um and your parents and I mean so this
was a to John's point I know he was
joking but to hit on that I was being
100 serious buying buy me buying your
car from your parents or buying your
house from your parents sometimes
they'll give you a great deal and it
often comes with strings or sometimes
they yeah but they're not gonna live in
it forever and ever yeah
but it will be their home it will be
their home that is true so let's listen
the thought that you're gonna buy this
house for 250 000 and move into it and
your parents are still going to be in
there thought number one yeah are they
going to keep the master bedroom while
they live there
yes number two
are they going to have opinions on how
you decorate the kitchen in the yard
well we'll wait to do all of that until
they're out we'll keep it the same as
what they have it right now it sounds so
good in your heart I'm just telling you
how long will they be there with you
Carly because I know they're building so
when will they move they're they're
hoping to move um in the spring of 2024.
okay so yep nine months
so this winter we would be living with
them okay yeah
um at least there's lots of uh lots of
warmth and joy outside in uh Fargo in
the winter y'all won't be cooped up in
the same house together
okay why the rush Carly why do you want
to do that right now that's a good
question
so they're building
it okay
um but we just thought we would try to
get our house sold just to get it you
know so we have our money
um to be able to take that amount off of
the 250 000. well sure but why wouldn't
you just do that in the spring too
I mean I yeah
why would you jump the gun I guess
what's the what's the rush yeah what
keeps you from wanting just to move in
versus having your own house now and you
guys living and just saying Yeah by
March we're gonna make this transition
together right they move out you move in
I guess I'm not sure I um
I guess we could wait
yeah and I think Carly a lot of people
have fear around the real estate market
because it's like oh my gosh interest
rates are up uh is there a bubble what's
gonna happen but I mean for the most
part houses aren't getting cheaper right
so if anything you'll probably even make
possibly more money on your current home
in six months than you even will now
um but I would yeah from a relational
standpoint it might be wise just to to
pump the brakes a little bit you guys
don't have this urgent decision that you
have to make
um so moving in and making the time
frame you know overlap very small if
needed uh because are they do they need
any cash out of their house or I guess
they're doing a construction loan
yeah so they they would be using the
loan money to be able to help build okay
okay
um Carly how much for you and your
family not your parents but you guys uh
financially where are you at do you guys
have debts do you have savings
um so right now we have a car payment
and then the house mortgage came in how
much how much do you owe in the car
on the car how much do
Force how much
477 a month
I know how much is it how much is the
total loan do you know
you know how much the total loan is
it's a lease okay
and when is it up
uh in the next year in the next year
okay how much do you guys make a year
we're making around 145
000 a year okay growth yeah good for you
guys okay
um well yeah the lease is just do you
guys have cash uh
at all any savings so we're in our
savings we have about 14
000. okay
okay
um yeah I mean from a financial
standpoint I mean the lease is the only
you know somewhat debt that you're
carrying and you guys have a good
emergency fund in place so I would I
mean just at this point it's more the
relational factor that kind of has us
pausing
and and probably Our advice would be
just to slow it down so there's not any
messiness of moving in with parents and
and all of that yeah here's what I would
say and it's so easy to do handshake
deals and hey we'll just take care of it
and
you've heard me say this a lot but we we
think in pictures but we speak in words
and so when they say hey we'll take care
of it you might see free and when they
say we'll take care of it they might say
we're gonna do the paperwork and give
the ten thousand dollar charge to you
guys
and it's all gonna be awkward when you
get an inspection done on their house
to find out hey the roof has a leak in
it or there's a problem with the um
sewer system or whatever
and it's going to be a challenge when
they say hey how about you just pay us
you don't even have to get a loan no
we're going to go through a bank we're
going to make this as clean as possible
because we want you to stay our parents
we want to still be
um you all till yeah we want to love
each other
yep and that was our plan was to go
through the blank the bank to do the
loan and everything like that
um what I know about building is it
never comes in on time
yeah and so I think an idea in Fargo
we're going to be done in the spring
the chances of it running to next fall
are very high
maybe not so they do it they have a
cabin that they're going to be moving
into so it's going to be a for sure like
March April move out whether or not the
building is done or not you know they'll
just be getting started so I I think you
could do something as simple as write up
a personal contract in your home
computer and hand it to your dad and say
I'm going to buy this house for this
much and we're going to close April
whatever April 1st and then you and your
husband now y'all have this much time to
get your house sold get some cash saved
up get that stupid lease out of your
life or
um figure out how you don't have to
re-up it right and you can you have a
long run way to get into this thing yeah
and Carly what's the what is the reason
you're choosing this house over
something else
is that what you said yeah yeah
um the location and the size of the
house and
um are they cutting your deal on it
the tree yeah they're cutting a seal too
yeah so you guys wanted to upgrade
anyways you wanted more square footage
yeah our house right now is small so
yeah we would see you you were going to
want to anyways okay perfect yep that's
great so yeah
um yeah everything John said I totally
agree with and I just wanted to make
sure always with these family deals
sometimes and if I ask that question
here at the end
is because it's like oh Mom and Dad are
they're they're moving and the child at
home ever the whole family wants to keep
it in the name and we'll be the ones
that sacrifice and they want to sell it
to us because they wanted to stay in the
family yeah like there's some there's
some weird like strings and all that so
just making sure that you guys as just
you and your husband Carly and your
family that this is a move that you guys
would have done anyways Mom and Dad are
moving at the same time that's great
we'll cut a great deal we'll figure it
out move forward just making sure
there's no
uh weirdness of any pressure feeling
like you guys have to make this move
when you may not even want to so thanks
for the call this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation in
prayer is hallow hallow is the number
one Prayer app in the world and they're
giving you three months free to get
started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice
mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and
remember Halo is giving you 90 days free
imagine the peaceful habits you can
establish in 90 days go to hollow.com
Ramsay today and follow the simple
prompts to start your free 90-day trial
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show
John you've been
hard at work I would say for a bit now
uh because well you're you're always
hard at work not just for a bit but
always I'm glad that felt so good that
you recognized but the stuff you talk
about especially on your show you know
when you look in the lane specifically
with anxiety with depression all these
things that are so intertwined that are
continuing to increase I mean you you we
all see the studies and the stats and
everything coming out that it just
continues to be a problem and so this is
something a subject that you've really
honed in on and then in turn have
written an entire book about right and
I've also experienced it in my own house
right yeah yeah and so um so I've been
talking a lot about on the show it's
called building an unanxious life
um and we'll just keep talking about it
by the way but listen
um you know those little blurbs on the
back of the book of a book jacket where
famous people tell you how great the
book is right they all love it well team
handed me this paper and as I started
reading these I don't think these are
real but here's what they wrote
Advance praise for building a
non-anxious Life by Dr John deloney
Jocko writes good book pro tip throw the
dust jacket away so you never have to
look at his face thanks Jacob
Kelly Daniels my producer says well well
well we finally wrote something with
that PIN instead of twirling it between
his fidgety little fingers
personality Ken Coleman said this book
is 10 times better than all of my books
combined I sleep with an autographed
copy on my bedside table Dr Delaney's my
hero thanks again that means the world
so great so gracious Dr Jordan Peterson
writes
this book is an analog of the structure
of existence itself that puts you on the
border of chaos and that was actually
pretty funny I think the team made those
up but listen you can get the book right
now it's 20 bucks and we're gonna throw
a whole bunch of things at you to
encourage you to get it early it will be
in your mailbox October 3rd when it
releases and if you wait till October
3rd that's great too it's going to be in
all the stores and you can get it
anywhere you buy books but
know this I I kept in mind all the the
latest neuroscience and nerd stuff and I
kept in mind all the professionals and
practitioners that I talk to across the
country but I wrote it for you
if you are into the the neural Pathways
and the way chemicals in your brain
interact this book probably is not for
you if you're interested in what can I
do right now to help my kids what can I
do right now to help my house my
classroom my workplace with that person
you look in the mirror I wrote this book
for you and it is simple it's a path
towards a non-anxious life so that your
body doesn't have to get your attention
all the time with those alarms so Rachel
that's what we're doing go to
ramsaysolutions.com 20 bucks and get
your copy now it's so good because I
feel like for some people you know they
hear the word anxiety or I mean like
anything in that mental health space and
some people are very intrigued by it and
they're like oh my gosh I want to learn
more I want to know what's going on with
me and then some people are like uh like
no that's that's not for me that stuff
people get stuck in just the therapy
Loop of life and talk about feelings and
we like we gotta get stuff done you got
to move on like there's like kind of
that grit mentality almost so just first
for just a second talk about like what
it what is anxiety if it's something
that people did you hear that word a lot
and there's some people that aren't
going to go and dive in to it even if
maybe they have it they don't even
realize it but you know when you're when
you're talking about a non-anxious life
what would an anxious life be so I used
to be a Hold the Line nerd if you will
and I would push my nerd glasses up my
nerd nose and say hey anxiety is
actually a clinical term only for
Diagnostics and you have to be trained
and it's one of these things and it's in
the DSM or the in the 10 codes and
then I started acting like a human being
and say everybody uses the word anxiety
and it can mean burnout it can mean
chronic stress it can mean I can't
breathe and my husband walks in the door
and I don't know why because I actually
like that guy it can be your kid walks
in and slams the door and just heads
straight to the room and you are just
brush it off and say oh that's just
teenagers but you know in your guts
something's wrong with that relationship
so that's the way we use it as our inner
culture we just throw it all under I'm
anxious he's got anxiety right so I just
went with that this time and I'm not
trying to reinvent the wheel what I tell
folks is the the last study I looked at
said 50 of the United States experiences
some form of burnout chronic stress or
anxiety and the other half of America is
married to them so you can say this
isn't you I don't have nothing to do
with this but it's your wife yeah or
your husband yeah it's your boss it's
your son it's your daughter it's your
husband it's it's this is impacting you
in some it's your politician that's
screaming their head off about it's all
coming down when it probably isn't so
this is a really important read and the
world in my opinion doesn't need another
clinical treaties it we need a what do I
do right now yep and there is a time for
counseling there is a time for
medication you and I both see a
counselor we're pretty open about that
both of our spouses see counselors
that's really important
but man we have thrown a lot of
counselors at the problem and a lot of
medication at the problem globally and
it is continuing to escalate and so this
is what can I do in my house right now
yeah and let's start there and made it
as simple as possible and as tactile as
possible but anxiety it's just your body
trying to get your attention it is a
smoke alarm in your kitchen that
something's on fire
it's not the problem what's the problem
is the fire and this book points you to
the fires in your life and how to deal
with them yeah and in every area right
so it's so good so powerful so you go to
ramseysolutions.com and pre-order
building a non-anxious life today again
if you pre-order you get a bunch of free
great stuff and uh it will be delivered
in your mailbox October third awesome
and for those of you um in that can be
in the Nashville area October 5th we are
going to have a madhouse live event here
on Ramsey Ramsey's campus October 5th
seven o'clock it is going to be wheels
off we're going to have a book launch
party I'll be speaking we'll have some
guests show up don't miss it um you can
get on ramseysolutions.com and check out
tickets and all that tickets there
awesome it's gonna be fun so great all
right up next we have Casey in
Fayetteville hey Casey welcome to the
show
hey there thank you so much for having
me I feel grateful oh well thanks for
calling how can we help
yeah so um I am currently serving active
duty in the Army
um I actually just completed 10 years
um thank you Casey for your service oh I
appreciate that thank you
um unfortunately I've sustained some
pretty significant injuries that is
requiring me to be medically separated
hopefully medically retired just
depending on disability rating and all
of that
um my question to you is I have a
remaining debt that I have is ten
thousand dollars in student loans
um and I'm kind of in a pickle where I
have the money to pay them off
um right now however my situation is if
I get a high enough disability rating
the VA takes care of those loans for you
um now I expect to be separated probably
by next spring my guess is March April
just given how long these things take
um obviously with the you know interest
rates kicking back in and payments you
know starting back up in October it's
kind of made me sit down and think about
this like do I want to just go ahead and
knock this out if I'm not growing this
interest or come when I'm separated you
know I have the high like I do have a
high enough disability rating to get
those taken care of for me and so I'm
just kind of in like a dilemma of how to
go about this
yeah how much do you have in savings
total
um I have we have roughly about 25 000
in a high yield savings five thousand in
a CD and then I have 20 000 in a Thrust
savings plan that's kind of but I just
recently started uh for my retirement
a Thrift Savings Plan from your
retirement
yeah yeah so it's it's a it's a program
that's in like the military
um it's an account you could you can set
up at any time and you can put a certain
percentage of your paycheck towards it
gotcha gotcha and put it into certain
different funds okay perfect but that's
more considered retirement correct
yes yes okay
um so for you guys is there a chance
that in March that they would come back
and say no that they wouldn't be able to
take care of it because of the amount of
disability that you're looking at
yeah I mean it's definitely possible
that I don't get a high enough rating
and that's the thing I don't know what
my rating will be until it happens so
it's kind of like you know I I could
hope for it and it doesn't happen and
then I'm just stuck with that much more
money for sure which I could pay for it
but it just seems yeah silly so yeah for
sure well yeah yeah Casey I mean if I
were you today I I would just go pay it
off and I would be you know detached
from that loan and be done with it and
continue to live my life and you'll make
different decisions I think between now
and even spring because you guys are
debt free so
um and again they may come back and you
know maybe you would have had it paid
off but here's the deal you have the
money now and for me I'm like as soon as
possible that I can not have debt in my
life that's the route nine months of
sleep you could pay for ten thousand
bucks that's right so I'd pay it off
Casey and thanks again for your service
thank you
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Rachel Cruz hosting at this hour with Dr
John deloney taking your calls and
listen you guys if you are a new
listener and you hear terms like is that
snowball or the baby steps or all this
kind of like lingo around specifically
money and you're thinking hey I want to
get on board because we have new people
all the time YouTube podcasts I mean
there's so many of you guys that are
just tuning in and seeing hey what can I
do now to take control of my money and
you're listening to us and so the best
way to plug in and the best way to
understand where you're at and what to
do next is our get started guide so if
you go to ramseysolutions.com and you
click on that it's really going to help
uh take you know what's in your head and
what you're thinking and kind of
figuring out and just put it right in
front of you and to say hey here is your
next step so again it's uh it's it's a
button called get started but really
it's this kind of thing you fill out to
really understand where you're at today
and help you in your financial Journey
when it comes to rimsy Solutions as we
guide you and have some of this these
terms and all of that too so go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button uh to figure out your
next step in your financial Journey all
right up next we have Jamie and Memphis
hey Jamie welcome to the show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
absolutely how can we help
uh so my husband and I we have a blended
family we have four children
um two live with us and two live with
their mother
we're communicating with our 16 year old
and her mother regarding her first car
we're trying to encourage a cash car and
we'll contribute to the purchase and
possibly just buy the whole car if we
can agree on the kind of car and
everything but her mother's suggesting
financing a vehicle that's a bit more
expensive and doesn't seem to have any
insight into the Ramsey principles do
you have any advice on how we should
handle this situation
yeah don't let your kid get stuck in the
middle of this
I know I know that sounds so hard
but if if and that means what making the
parents make the decision that means if
if bio mom is
um makes it sound like she's a robot if
biological mother is the word this kid
lives and she wants to make a decision I
think you sit down and say hey we don't
believe in taking out loans in our house
and you can look at our home and our
home is is peaceful we've made these
choices
um and in no way are we going to
disparage by our mom at all but this is
the life we've chosen we're willing to
give you a car
um
that you won't owe any money on you're
not going to have any payments on
because that's what we believe
then you state your piece you put on the
table what you're able to put on it and
if she chooses to go with what her
mother is telling her I would not roast
her because she's caught in the middle
of two different households with two
different sets of values
that makes sense
yes that makes perfect sense and I think
that I think I think your promise to her
is I'll sit with you when you're
complaining about having to make this
payment in two and a half years or you
have to sit out a semester of college
because you can't you have to pay this
loan and you can't afford your tuition
I'll sit with you and I'll I'll even
pick up the breakfast Tab while you're
agonizing and complaining about it
um but this is the choice you're making
and here here we go and here's this
option right here
well I think um her mother is suggesting
taking on the payment herself and we
just don't think that that's a great
idea and of course it's not necessarily
our business to be in her finances
um but again we would just prefer like I
feel like just the teachable moment for
her because I didn't have the financial
knowledge at that age that I wish I had
so um yeah it's a teachable moment but I
also I there's just something about a 16
year old caught between two households
and if I don't do this then I'm gonna do
this my mom's gonna feel like I'm doing
this just for dad and my stepmom and
that means I'm being disloyal to I mean
you're asking a lot of a 16 year old
trap between these two homes and so it
is a teachable moment but when you're in
a split house like this
those teachable moments I I mean they
spread out over years and we won't I
never want to sacrifice a relationship
in this moment for two different uh
values in a household unless there's
something about safety right
um like I would probably dig my heels in
on bio mom wants to give my kid a
smartphone and I'm saying no I'd
probably throw a fit about that or by
mom lets me drink at home and I'm only
14. I'd throw a fit about that in terms
of your mom wants to take out a loan we
don't think that's wise but we know you
love your mom and here's what we're
willing to do if you want to do that
um and and do your best not to throw
this child's mother under the bus
because this child will always look in
the mirror and know half of me is her
and if she's dumb if she's making bad
choices then that means I'm dumb and
that's a lot to put on a 16 year old
right I agree yeah and Jamie and I think
your heart and those what you call
teachable moments I think what John just
said I think that is one and I think
sitting down and being honest with your
16 year old without you know running her
mom into the ground by any means but
just to say hey here's what we've
realized about money here's things that
we've learned you know and that could be
everything from budgeting that can be
whatever it is and to say we've just
realized here's what debt does to us and
as and as a family we've realized you
know man I put stress on us you know
even your husband's saying golly I would
lose sleep at night thinking about the
bills that I had to be paid like we've
just realized life has so much more
peace when there's not debt so
regardless of what happens with your mom
and the car and all that just know from
us from Jamie and her dad like this is
where we stand and this is why we stand
here and we want to walk with you and be
there for you but but from a wisdom
perspective when it comes to money we
believe that this is the best way to
handle money and there's a reason why
and Dave's talked about this
um in his personal life and I love the
story that he had a closed captioning
not available
and then he was bragging about it was
his new lease
and his buddies Dave Ramsey and what did
Dave do he's like let's go check out
this car in my driveway I want to go see
it Dave didn't turn around and lecture
him about it so if your 16 year old
decides to get this new car that Mom
wants to buy and finance for her and
pick up the payments on
and she brings that house that car into
your driveway make the first thing you
do not well was that about payments say
hey baby show me your new car and run
out and look at it and don't sacrifice
relationship right now because this
again she's caught in the middle let's
lean on relationship whenever possible
great thank you so much for your help
you got it absolutely thanks for thanks
for thinking through that that gets
messy I know well and with that
mentality of the of the kids that are
stuck ping-ponging between right it is
so easy to get caught in the middle and
for parents how important is it to to
protect your kids in that and to set
them up well well and
I can also see bio mom saying y'all
aren't buying my daughter a car like
that's my job and I don't have the money
to do it so I'm gonna do it like this or
she's getting her esteem because her
daughter's gonna drive CarX there's so
many variables here that that 16 year
old has no business wading through yeah
and I never in a in a divorced household
I never want a kid to feel like I'm
being disloyed to one parent yes which
they do I'm never sacrificing my values
I just I just don't want them in that
mess and so the best adults can agree
together man that's so good and if they
can't
let's figure out the the path of least
resistance there yep so helpful all
right up next we have will in Atlanta
hey Will welcome to the show we're up
against the clock man let's go quick
all right uh okay let me get right to my
question so at the end of every month I
have a little bit of space left in my
budget I just want to know what should I
do with that little bit of space do you
have do you have debt right now
no man no debt no dad do you have a
emergency fund yes ma'am nice are you on
base so you're maybe it's four five and
six are you funding retirement
uh I'm signing up for my 403b next month
oh good for you do you have kids
no no do you have a house
I'm renting an apartment right now good
okay that's awesome I think you put in
an envelope and send it to attention
Rachel Cruz
I'll take that extra account she's got a
car fund she's trying to trying to put
money in so so yeah well at this point
how much did you say you have extra per
month
uh
usually comes out to about like 60 bucks
at the end of the month okay I spend
five dollars less than I allocate for
groceries every week or something like
that oh good for you down to the penny
that's awesome well so will I mean
incredible honestly I mean the 60 I
would say yeah if there's a little bit
if you want to up you're out to eat buy
some you know you can you're to the
point that you are you're funding
retirement you don't have a mortgage
right now so the next big thing that
you'd save for is probably a house so if
that is something you want to look into
and say hey I'm going to put some of
this money away in a high yield savings
and I'm just gonna be diligent with it
that's great but it's 60 bucks it's not
a ton of money uh yeah so it's not 600 a
month you know which you know you would
look at and say okay what are we gonna
do so
um I would you could up your lifestyle
up a little bit will if you want enjoy a
little bit of that 60. or or I've heard
I'll put it away people say you get
wealthy ten dollars at a time
put it away go either way but you're
doing great nothing major on fire right
now will well done well done well that
uh wraps up the show thanks to all the
guys in the booth John thank you for
hosting thank you America for listening
this is the Ramsay show
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work they
love and create actual healthy
relationships I am Ramsey personality
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with
Ramsay personality Dr John deloney and
it is a free call anywhere in America to
talk about in your life and your money
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five so give us a call all right to
start us off this hour we have Joshua in
Baltimore hey Joshua welcome to the show
hey thank you for having me absolutely
I'm a huge fan um my my question is
though
I'm 25 years old I just graduated
college
um
from the Russia's Morgan State and I
have about 17 K saved up but I I got it
I got myself into a column I didn't need
one I just needed a car at the time it's
about 28 000 and my student loan just
started so that's about 28 000 students
so my question is
which one should I pay down first I'm
trying to follow the debt snowball
um thing that you guys talk about yeah
so I paid so I prayed on the student
loan first or the car first because I
was thinking about getting a second job
um for you Joshua how did you save up 17
000 as a recent college grad
so I'm an engineer uh I had I had a job
with the construction company before I
graduated so since student loan was on
the freeze I was just saving up my money
as much as I can I normally saves up
about close to 2K every month and I just
kept on saving from there from November
all the way through April before they
released me so but I have I have a good
amount of savings I didn't really need
to get the car but I was like at the
time I just got an accident so I really
needed I needed a car at the time so I
was thinking if I was just managed to
sell a car he takes an auction but I
wanted to know shy yeah how much how
much is that car worth
it's worth 26 000. oh yeah I would sell
it today so I'm sure I think I would
sell it I'll sell it right now
and if even if you have to take a
thousand or two thousand dollars to
close it out I would do that and dude
you cut your debt load in half
I'd probably take ten thousand of that
17 grand and go buy a car and take the
rest of it and start paying those two
loans off
okay that's okay so so if you have it's
26 you'll pull 2 000 out of your 17 000
so you'll have 15 000 left
yeah go take eight nine ten thousand
um
as cheap honestly Joshua at this point
like I would just get as cheap of a car
as possible I mean that's gonna run and
that's you know reliable and all of that
um and then yeah throw the rest at your
debt because you could depending on the
car you buy I mean within 30 days you
could have just 20K left of student
loans to pay and with the rate that you
save I mean you'll be able to to knock
that out are you are you in a different
job though is that what you said
yeah I am um because they they released
us in April so okay I work for new I'm a
field engineer I work for a new company
okay and how much do you make a year
81. oh good for you and is that is that
less than what you're making at your
other job or more no it's 1K more than I
was making my other job I started my
first one was like 80. this one's 81
which isn't bad so it's an improvement
yeah so hey and Joshua I want you to
like be ready for this
they're gonna clown on you when you come
rolling up in a forty five hundred
dollar car
they will clown on you they will say hey
we know what we're paying you what are
you doing
and you can just smile real big and say
I'm solving for Freedom guys
I ain't nobody gonna own me I'm out I'm
out I'm off I'm I took the red pill and
the green pill I'm out of the Matrix I'm
done and uh okay all right dude because
I've done it man I rolled up to my job
as a dean of students at a law school in
a 3 500 truck
and man we had some good hearty laughs
out in the parking lot with some of my
colleagues and
um
man sure was cool never making a car
payment or a truck payment
I just got out yeah because my my car
payment John is like 486 a month but I
normally pay 600 to pay down faster yeah
but I got tired of making a payment so I
just wanted to know like which one would
be more much smarter but I'm definitely
going to take take you on racial device
as far as like sell that cards and again
Joshua I'm like when you're looking at
you know and the kind of the math we
just ran that we're like yeah if you go
and you take you know two grand out of
your 17 to pay the difference if you
need to you got fifteen thousand dollars
left and I'm like in a dream world I'm
like what if you yeah what if you found
a five thousand dollar car again it's
not it's not it's not a great beautiful
car but it's something yeah and then you
take and you take the rest of that 10
grand you're gonna have eighteen
thousand dollars left and your student
loans and I'm like you and if you said
you were willing to work an extra job
you're six months yeah I mean that's
five months Joshua you could be
completely debt free out of this all
this mess and then when you stay with
that intensity you'll be able to save up
a lot of cash sell the crappy car the 5
000 car step up to a ten thousand dollar
car and then you're just moving right
along and continuing to save for an
emergency funds like if you're like in
10 years I'm calling you and asking you
for a job
you know what I'm saying like you like
this is how I mean this is a 24 36 month
turnaround but this is how family
legacies are changed right absolutely
well done Joshua we're excited for it
awesome man and that's what's that's the
stuff that is so exciting when you look
at the specific numbers in a situation
like Josh was
and you actually put it down you do a
plan his whole world could be different
in 10 months yes like it's not that long
I mean like you could really say oh my
gosh you know by Next by Summer
completely debt free money in the bank a
paid for car and you're just Trucking
right along versus stretching everything
out spending everything not having
Saving right extra over here extra over
here something breaks you gotta get a
credit card for that yes I mean and hey
all of it don't underestimate like
Rachel we're just talking about like
it's just 10 months it can be all be
different
and almost every day of that 10 months
is going to be miserable it'll be hard
your friends are going to laugh at you
your that car is not going to get the
gas mileage you want it's gonna smell
funny you're gonna be sending all this
money to your student loans it's not
going to be a pleasant ride so trust
people that you hear on the debt free
screens trust the millions of people who
go through this program on the back end
that freedom the whole the lights come
on in their home that they didn't even
know are off man and so it's worth that
grind to get to the other side yeah I've
never had somebody you may have I've
never had somebody go be debt free and
say I wish I hadn't done that I've never
heard that ever I know I've said often I
wish I hadn't eaten that second
cheeseburger or I wish I hadn't of
whatever never heard somebody say
ah I wish I hadn't paid that bill that's
what I always tell people I'm like
listen if you hate it if you hate being
debt free you can always get back in if
that's what you choose and that's the
life you want you can always do it but
there's something about living in this
mentality when you don't know someone
anything nothing and the autonomy Joshua
and at your age Mike you just graduate
you're an engineer you're such a sharp
guy in this situation I'm like it's just
a few of those decisions painful hard
decisions sometimes when you're in the
midst of it but it's just saying hey
this this and this for a period of time
and then you look up and you know not
not even 10 months and then fast forward
two years three years and I'm like oh my
gosh like it's just a completely
different world versus staying in the
same monotonous habit that you're just
in and that's the problem John I think
is that people they're comfortable where
they are and it kind of is working I
mean you don't even like his situation
he this is a great example I'm like yeah
28 000 car loan twenty thousand dollars
too long yeah I think we could kind of
just truck along pay you know an extra
thousand you know and you're in it for
for three four years oh man I need new
tires we can just Finance those aisles
[Music]
and I dug my whole deeper right yeah
that's right that's right so the habits
you guys if you're not happy with the
situation you're in financially that
means the way you're handling money the
way you're viewing it it has to change
and change is uncomfortable but change
is necessary to get a different result
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save to 40 off everything site-wide go
to blinds.com for more information
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
our question of the day comes from
neighborly
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services neighborly is the
place to find Reliable help for your
home from the most trusted locally owned
businesses like Glass Doctor provision
garage door service and Mr Handyman
visit neighborly.com to find home
experts available to you and we wanted
to just pause for a second and just say
to the neighborly families or family of
franchises and to the Bidwell family in
particular that our hearts and our
prayers go out to you guys Mike Bidwell
was a really strong leader and he's
going to be missed and we are really so
so incredibly sorry
um
he was yep and he passed away suddenly
and we um this company and him and his
family and everything that they've
they've done is just absolutely
incredible and it was just a really
shocking really sad sad day for them so
we're thinking about you guys yeah our
broken hearts are with you
today's question comes from Deb in Texas
Deb writes I've always tried to be
organized with my finances my husband on
the other hand never had any control on
spending we've been married for 16 years
and I just discovered he had a Best Buy
credit card balance of ten thousand
dollars wow the same card he hid from me
two years ago after arguing every day he
finally sat down and talked about the
problem we started the baby steps in
March and did Financial Peace University
with Jade I was so happy because I
started to see a change he even cut his
credit cards in one of the classes I
recently told him that I needed to add
his other bank account to every dollar
budget to keep track and what came out
of his mouth was you have the other bank
information you have you want to have
control over this one too
once again I feel hopeless and tired I
know that our money problems and the
lack of communication will eventually
kill our marriage actually that's not
what's going to kill your marriage
it's going to kill your marriage as you
have a husband who lies to you regularly
what's going to kill your marriage is
y'all have not sat down in a room with
the marriage counselor and said
the marriage we had where we trusted
each other where you weren't trying to
be in control of everything and y'all
were Partners in this thing and he was
honest and was a partner in this thing
as well
that we that's over and we have to
rebuild it y'all haven't done that and
so what you're doing is blaming money
what you're doing is blaming the lack of
communication those are symptoms of two
people not on the same page
and so
um
Rachel this marriage is incorisis and
this is a Turn All the Lights On turn
the music off we're going to counseling
right now yeah because we have to decide
if we want to stay married or not yep
well and it's one of those things that
you know when you fix just the symptom
and you don't fix what's really going on
it's going to Bubble Up right so like
and that's what's happening it's like
okay well we fixed that he cut up the
credit card which is great
but understanding we talk about this a
lot on the show is that yeah your money
problems aren't usually money problems
it's usually marriage problems and so
the fact either couples are like yep
you're right we're gonna sign page cut
the credit card and we're in this
together right so this story could have
been oh yeah we need the other account
for everyone absolutely yeah yeah here
it is and you keep trucking right
there's a there's a level of healing and
just the sense of we're on that we're in
this together and you are but when
statements like this arise and you can
start to see oh my gosh she doesn't he
doesn't trust me he doesn't want me to
see something
then you know underneath all of that it
hasn't been fixed and it may not even be
that he's doing something nefarious it
may mean
maybe you are overbearing maybe you are
in his business about every second of
everything and maybe he is being
dishonest because he feels genuine like
who knows what the issue is right
um more than likely he's hiding things
and lying to you right
um but whatever it is you have to get to
the bottom of that
um and what does that sound like in real
life let's just get brass tacks that
sounds like I will not be married to
somebody who continues to lie to my face
and put my family's financial future at
risk period
I will not be married to somebody who
hides money from me and from our kids
and who will not be in alignment with me
right I mean that's what we're talking
about here yeah and um I've said this
before and I'll say it again I think
that
Fidelity we talk about that cheating if
you will we only talk about that in a
did you hook up with somebody you're not
married to context yeah I think you can
cheat on your spouse with your hobbies
you can cheat on your spouse by working
100 hours a week 160 hours a week you
can cheat with alcohol you can be a
person who is not does not have Fidelity
in a relationship with a bunch of
different things yes yes and financial
infidelity is one of those things yep
absolutely and sadly it's one that we
see I mean not crazy often but enough
to know okay there's stuff that that
that is broken here and marriage is hard
right I mean stuff so hard always it's
stuff that you're working on but I think
the the point of bringing in a third
party even at this point
um for for Deb is what I what I would
encourage because obviously you guys are
trying to do this on your own which is
you know honorable but also to be able
to get to the root issue I think having
somebody to walk you through that ask
the right questions pinpoint The Right
Stuff
um is really crucial here's a good
analogy if you've been fixing your roof
for 16 years and it still leaks every
time it rains call a roofer yeah you
aren't getting the job done yeah for
whatever reason you don't have the
skills you don't have expertise whatever
you are not able to solve this problem
get a roofer you've been working on your
marriage for 16 years you've tried
programs you've tried shame you've tried
yelling you've tried uh arguments every
day you tried all these things tried
hiding money from each other it's not
working get a professional so good all
right up next we have Sarah in Los
Angeles hey Sarah welcome to the show hi
hello thanks for calling how can we help
um long time listener so happy to
finally online
um I have a question so I'm feel very
blessed we we have we're in a good place
in our lives with money
um however we have a rental property
that
um we've owned for a while my husband
and I in our family and a couple years
ago we had an opportunity to buy a house
and remodel it in the area that we
wanted and so that's we did that and
we're living in that house now and we
decided to keep our old primary
residence and make that into a rental
and then not tell it right away just say
she you know hold on to it see where we
are in two years and so here we are and
um talking about anxiety sometimes
it does cause a little bit of anxiety
because I want to be debt free but
um so we I just need to figure out if
it's worth me paying off that house or
just selling it
um Sarah how much is how much is the
house worth
that house is worth probably a million
dollars okay and how uh what do you owe
on it
3 45 okay and what other debt do you
guys have
that is the only debt we have just the
rental property other than our Prime
other than our primary what's your
primary yeah what what uh what mortgage
do you have on that how much do you owe
on it 600 okay how much you guys make a
year
between the two of us we make about 250.
okay
no wonder you're anxious your body's
trying to get your attention and let you
know
if one of y'all says the wrong thing at
work and gets fired you lose both houses
you lose everything yeah I know your
body would be failing you if it let you
sleep through the night with eight
hundred thousand dollars of Mortgage
Debt spread across two properties
like it would be failing you if it let
you sit next to it close to a million I
mean 600 yeah yeah it would be failing
you you know you hear what I'm saying
yeah I know your body's doing exactly
so tell me this yeah tell me this Sarah
what if you what if you sold it
and you clear about 600 on the rental
pay off your primary mortgage and you
have enough no debt
no I I totally every day that's what I
want so what keeps you what keeps you to
have the rental
the emotional attachment to okay to the
house itself it's not even emotional in
the sense that we have a son and
California real estate is very expensive
and we have other family whose kids are
moving away for that reason and we have
an opportunity to hold on to this house
to either help him buy up into a new
house to stay close to where we are
um I mean we have a very low interest
rate luckily we when we got it
refinanced it it was like a three
percent it's low property rate because
it's been in the family yeah you are
suffocating yourself to prop up some
fantasy that may or may not happen in 10
years
sell the house I promise he wants a mom
who's got peace in her heart and in her
home more than he's going to want to buy
some house in seven to ten years and if
the income was a different story Sarah
we could have a different discussion but
you guys make 250 and you have so much
so much Mortgage Debt I would I would
get rid of it pay off your primary
mortgage and live a peaceful life this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with Dr
John deloney and it's a free call
anywhere in the country at triple eight
eight two five five two two five all
right up next we have Lindsay in Chicago
hey Lindsay welcome to the show
hi there thank you for taking my call
absolutely how can we help
how can I help my 82 year old father who
is first generation here in the United
States from Poland change change their
mindset about money he won't spend it
I think you should solve world hunger
and the climate crisis first and then
you'll be prepared to do this do this
oh my goodness okay so his problem is
not that he doesn't have money it's to
spend it
yeah uh we lost my mom back in 2019 and
he she was she was the money person he
was not he was the worker and uh yeah
I had to uh
uh beg him to get the Daily Newspaper
because he loves it
but he didn't want to pay for it he
didn't want to paint it okay so can we
say this real quick Lindsay let's just
say oh this is this is a good problem
yeah usually it's the opposite this is
the opposite and they're like my parents
have to come and you know live with us
because they're broke so so we're on a
we're I would say on the on
I don't want to say Better or Worse side
but we're probably just like a side to
be honest I would pick your side Lindsay
just just know that just know that so
yes I'm very grateful I remember being a
young kid and I went into my granddad's
garage and he had coffee cans in there
and in one coffee can or nails that he
straightened and another coffee can was
just string that he picked up when he
would go for his morning walks and I
remember asking my dad why does he have
cans of straightened nails and string
and he said
your granddad fought Nazis
your granddad knows what it's like to be
somewhere and they're coming for you
your granddad went through the Great
Depression
your granddad understands and so that
that's understand suffering at a level
that there is no stores to buy nails at
there's no metal left to buy Nails right
and so that stuff is not just a decision
at some point that stuff gets wired into
your nervous system when you're a kid
and so I'm thinking about your dad being
born what in the 40s and 50s in Poland
he's first generation born here okay
okay
same thing yep okay with parents that
got out
right yeah so he's wired into his his
little one and two and three and four
and five-year-old nervous system this is
how you live because it can go bad at
any SEC right and so now he's 81 and the
most prosperous time in human history
and his daughter's like Dad will you buy
a Coke ride right
what do you want him to spend money on
uh
vacations
or
I can find an example like the newspaper
that he loves so much maybe magazines or
crossword puzzles or you know some to
keep his brain active
what is he what's he how much money does
he have
um okay uh you may not even know one 160
I'm the person the 160 in cash
and
um 30 and a 401k
okay so he doesn't have a lot right no
but 400 in a paid off house uh yeah so
it's the house is paid off he doesn't
have many expenses right he's got no
debt he's got very little expenses uh
electric and that's it the property tax
is a reason what's he living off of this
160. security finally yeah well and so
to be Stark
he has won heart episode away he can
burn through 160 plus 30 in an afternoon
in an ER
okay and so his his
tentativeness is too far like buy a
newspaper for crying out loud right and
also we don't need to go take a 20 000
vacation yeah he's I mean he doesn't
have it's not like he I thought you were
gonna tell him he had a million dollars
and and I would say yeah he needs to go
on a vacation it might be that you're
struggling with your dad has worked
really hard his whole life
yeah and you want him to have some peace
and some smiles and it might be you
putting together a cool non-expensive
thing because my guess is the thing that
would bring him the most Joy at this
stage in life is seeing his baby girl
smile from ear to ear
wow
oh yes so what if you said what if
instead of trying to make him spend
money that he's uncomfortable spending
what if you sat down and said hey my
six-year-old loves spending time with
you can we make that a regular monthly
thing that you can both look forward to
all that I mean you're talking about
magic we go for a walk at a golf course
and and steal golf balls would you go to
the zoo like just make up crap that a
six-year-old's gonna like that that
six-year-old's gonna tell at his funeral
when he's 26 and your dad passes away
wow right does that make sense it sure
does that's it's deep and profound and I
love it
but I want everyone listening you didn't
want him to spend money you want to see
your dad happy and for you happiness is
with a really nice vacation
for your dad happiness is going to be my
parents survived hell and got us over
here and I've scratched and clawed and
scratched and clawed to get to this
moment
the thing that brings me the most Joy is
my baby girl being happy and my grand
baby being real real happy
right okay yeah and if we put it on the
schedule then everybody knows it's here
and everybody's looking forward to it
that's a great great idea yeah and even
if it's walking in the forest picking up
string and tell your six-year-old hey
you all have to get 15 mushrooms and 15
rocks before you come back in the house
all right let's do it
but it's about their time together which
will be fun
hey he the freaking Lottery when he got
you as His Daughter by the way
oh so nice no I'm not actually I'm kind
of a jerk but I tell the truth and he
did really he did really good by you
that's awesome oh so great I'm so glad
you called because I think that that's
like a that's a great example of a you
know you're looking at a situation
thinking money's money's the Avenue
but it's it's a tool sure in life to
create things and create memories and
experiences and all of it but really
though what people are searching for is
peace searching for Joy searching for
happiness connection relationship all of
that and so Lindsay I'm so glad that you
call them because I think that's just a
it's a it's a good wake-up call an
example of what people are longing for
truly in life well and a few years ago
so this is our story in our house a few
years ago
we got on a real big kick to pay some
stuff off we're going to be uh not
gazelle intense we're a rocket ship
intense kind of insane yeah but we had
to get away we have little kids and so
we jokingly went to a KOA and we invited
a couple friend of ours and their kids
it was so fun and now it's become an
annual state park Adventure we go to
state parks all over but but we realize
the time together and the convenience
and the silliness whether we're overseas
or whether we're right here for that
particular vacation now I'm all about
going overseas and doing that wild stuff
but for the purpose of this vacation
it's been magic and if we hadn't done it
at the beginning we would have thought
the only way to Vacation the only way to
peace is this twenty thousand dollar
vacation totally man for four hundred
dollars for 300 bucks you can have like
wild fun time with your kids time and
another part of her call John was about
how do I change my dad's mindsets yeah
you don't but that part you know a lot
of people again they may not be in
Lindsay's situation we're like I just
want my parents to enjoy life more and
spend but it's the opposite it's like
how do I control my parents how do I
tell my parents to handle their money
better how do I get them to do X Y and Z
maybe not even in the money space but
you're thinking about that but yeah so
talk about that for a second on you
can't you you can't you can't you can't
change your parents mindset here's what
many many many many parents long for
they long to matter to their kids
a great gift you can give your dad well
he you know I'm just making this up
right yeah hey Dad we're thinking about
getting a new car should we get
a Chevy Silverado a Ford F-150 or the
tundra uh
for you right and hey Dad can you help
these things when you're in town There's
Something About hey Dad you experience
this when you're a kid or something hey
Mom can you help me think through give
your parents a purpose and that's the
path if there's gonna be one to to mind
shift change it's to them helping you
out yep so good so so good well again
free call anywhere in the country at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we'll be back
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us netsuite worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com Ramsay
that's netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show
up next we have Cody and Lancaster
Pennsylvania hey Cody welcome to the
show
hey Rachel hey John it's good to hear
from you guys I I must admit it's a
great birthday gift to be able to talk
to you guys I'm pretty excited happy
birthday Cody how old are you man
birthday's not till tomorrow but yeah
it's exciting for me I've been listening
I'm a new listener but how old are you
enjoy listening to you guys uh 29
tomorrow nice hey you're gonna be 29 for
the next 30 years of your life
congratulations that's what my mom keeps
saying she's been 29 for about 30 years
or something like that yeah she loves
being 29 it's crazy
what's up a bit of a two-part question
for you guys if that's okay it's one
question but I I don't even know really
how to ask it in one in this thing so I
I bought a um I started a job in
insurance and uh 2019 we moved out to
Pennsylvania and this is my wife's
family lives here and we lived with her
parents for a little while and and we
had a brand new baby at the time and
that was absolutely toxic and I had to
get out of it so
um we wanted to buy as well because
we've been renting for so long and at
the time like we'll be close to family
so we wanted to buy any white just to be
in the state
and grow my business but we bought a
house that's more of like your your
first home buy it checked all the boxes
we needed but as as the last three years
have gone on we are you don't really
love the house we're realizing we like
more space we kind of think that we want
to move but the reason I have this
question every time I listen to the show
is because when I bought the house I
didn't have two years of consecutive
work test group because I'm
self-employed so my dad offered to put
his name on the house
I know I know I know don't hurt me but I
didn't so I I've only been with you guys
for a little bit but I know when I
listen and I I would never do it now nor
would I ever ever ask him to do it again
and I've already apologized to him for
doing it and he makes buckets of money
out in California doing what he's doing
anyway but it's not a problem for him
and he's never paid a single dollar at
all from our house the down payment
anything his name just had to be on the
thing in order for us to get it sure so
the idea was to get the house after I
worked for two years refinance it but
we're sitting here now three years later
and interest rates have more than
tripled so I I'm like is it it sounds so
dumb to refinance it
I I'm I'm a little torn because I want
his name off of it even though he
doesn't need his name off of it it's not
hurting him right the bills have never
gone unpaid we do our job but I just my
three options that I kind of come to are
are refinance or stack the deck until
we're ready to get the new house which
takes some time obviously or just pay it
off
uh in the next three three and a half to
four years because my income goes up
quite a bit each each year sure
um okay so I'm not I'm just not even
sure what to do but I just I'm not is it
wrong to hang him on the lawn or what
but how much how much are you how much
do you owe on the house
uh about 180 85 185 okay and how much
you make a year
uh well see that's the thing so my my
income has doubled over the last two
years and I get about a forty thousand
dollar increase each year
um I would say you have the last few
years and you hope to get in the future
yeah be very careful about making you
guys with yeah don't make financial
decisions based on this yeah I'm in 14
years I'm gonna be making yeah right be
careful about that right right and
that's why I don't want to I don't want
to go into like a really expensive house
or anything we also we're minimal people
we don't need a lot to be happy but our
income now I'd say by the end of this
year we'll probably clock in just under
I'd say probably somewhere around 90.
um
and then yeah because the majority of
everything that I make I get a giant
bonus in January depending on how annual
enrollment period goes for Medicare
because I do mostly Medicare okay so I
get a huge influx in the beginning of
the year and then I get like a monthly
payment through the rest of the year so
I just let it out I'm good at saving
because I have to spread myself out in
order to live so sure sure to that point
um do you guys have any other decks
uh no other debt well all right that's
why
um I we have a car that's going to be
completely paid off in general well in
December it's going to pay off okay
completely so other than that we just
have the house okay and you said I've
done the math I cut you off but uh well
after I've done the math and I know John
just corrected me and not to do that but
I've done the math in a conservative
manner as though I'm going to be
increasing my income only half of what
I've been increasing in the last three
years uh at about a twenty thousand
dollar increase because I just I like to
do my numbers extremely conservatively
sure and it should only take us
Earth about three to four years to pay
off the house I know Cody yeah that's my
numbers I mean honestly we don't know
what to do if I get his name off of it
or or if there's a way to do that
without refinancing it just seems so
dumb to refinance with such high
interest rates right now right no I hear
you yeah and I think if you talk to your
mortgage broker I mean maybe there's a
way around it you know there's sometimes
they have different stuff but I mean I
don't I don't know if that's gonna be a
situation for you but
I mean there's there's pardon me Cody
and I want to just say it that I'm like
listen you got you're not going to have
this house for 15 years you guys have an
aggressive plan you want the help yeah
you have an aggressive plan to pay it
off
um you sound as you're talking to us
like you're on track it there's not been
a situation so far with your dad and all
of that
yeah go ahead go ahead because I got a
kind of bird in here go ahead go well
well I was gonna say I mean like I want
to hear I want to hear the fire throw me
down oh we're gonna throw you down I
mean I would I would run the math and
just see okay
how much extra yeah because if you're if
you're interest rate is going to be you
know seven percent versus two percent or
whatever five percent what how much
extra is that how much longer will that
take you and you guys need to really run
these numbers out and you and your wife
need to sit down and ask okay is the
extra tens of thousands whatever it is
dollars
that we're going to pay if we refinance
to get him off and and clean slated you
know what is it worth it to us is that
because right now it doesn't sound like
the relationship is overly strained it
doesn't sound like he's a toxic person
and you and you because there's there
are people that call Cody listen though
and and it goes down the drain right
this is why we tell people not to do
this because it can go down the drain
really really fast and so if you were in
a situation we get this a lot where it's
like oh my gosh you know my her name's
on it and she's doing this and wanting
this and telling me here and and it's
just a disaster I would be like Noah and
I would get out of it no matter the
interest rate because of the toxic
relationship
but what you're saying is you're in
Pennsylvania he's in California
there's you guys seem to that it's okay
like you guys from a relationship
standpoint there hasn't been this big
you know explosion and you're gonna pay
it off in three years so all of that I
would be comfortable Cody if you just
keep keep going down the track and pay
it off in three years and be done with
it again if the timeline was different
if the relationship was different my
answer probably would change yeah dude I
hear one word coming through pay it off
when we when we don't really I I know
but listen I hear one word and that is
ego
you said it while Rachel was talking I
just want this personal accomplishment
bro you took out alone with your daddy
with your daddy's signature on it
it would almost be irresponsible right
now
for you to flex your ego
to the tune of however many thousands of
dollars that your ego would cost you and
to keep going your ego says I just got a
forty thousand dollar raise I'm gonna
get a forty thousand dollar next year in
a forty the year after that and a year
after that what you haven't experienced
is there is usually when you get into an
industry there's a low bar and then you
do a really great job and you go way up
and you go way up again but it does
begin to plateau
and while we're at it your ego says I
make ninety thousand dollars a year we
don't need this little house
we need something that better reflects
us and our and so what I want you to do
is take your ego and put it in a drawer
and say what is best for our family
right now in this season
and let's go from there because I'm I'm
super nervous that you have gone over
the next five years and given yourself a
forty thousand dollar raise in your mind
put that on paper and you and your wife
have talked about the house you could
afford
and I think that's not real
and that you've reverse engineered that
fantasy all the way back to this
discomfort with your dad's name is still
on your loan
well I have to admit it we're really not
I we bought this one at 185 and we're
actually thinking of coming closer to
you guys Tennessee Arkansas and with
what we're looking at it really would
only run somewhere between 200 to 250
which is what our house is kind of going
for right now okay so you'd keep that
flat which would be awesome good for you
and y'all are moving that's awesome too
I
I'm with Rachel I
ride this thing out it sounds like your
dad's a great guy and is not abusing his
relationship I would ride this out into
y'all are
committed to what your next steps are
yep and I just paid the sucker off yep
thanks America for listening thanks to
all you guys in the booth and John this
is the Ramsey Show
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsey Way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing healthy
relationships I am Rachel Cruz
Join This Hour by Dr John deloney and
we're taking your calls from anywhere in
the country at triple eight eight two
five five two two five so give us a call
and we will help you hopefully through a
situation that you have all right coming
up next we have Kelly in Savannah
Georgia hey Kelly welcome to the show
hey how are y'all we are doing great how
can we help
um I was calling because I'm trying to
figure out I'm currently in baby step
two and I'm trying to figure out if it's
okay for me to move now or should I wait
until I'm out of baby step two okay
um how much longer do you have in baby
step two
um
maybe around
four or five months okay
and what's the current living situation
that you're in that you're wanting to
move
um I am a single mom I had to move back
with my mom
um a couple years ago and I'm sharing a
room with my two sons and it's getting a
little cramps yeah
that's like being in a blender without
the top on right
I do have
for you know rent for I wouldn't
probably I wouldn't buy anything right
now but if you go and look at an
apartment or a condo or something do you
have other places in your area that you
feel like you could afford
there is I mean all of the places are
kind of expensive so it would make it
very tight for me so like moving fast
through big step two wouldn't really
happen too quickly but I mean I would be
able to you know move out and afford to
live on my own
what what about a Finish Line
okay if you knew by January Kelly looks
in the mirror and says Kelly January 1
we move out and we move out debt free
most of us can put up with just about
anything as the great Nietzsche says if
we have a big enough why I've got to get
out of here I want to preserve my
relationship with my kids I want to
preserve my relationship with my mom I
want to preserve my sanity
and also want to get out of debt so I'm
gonna put a clock on this thing and we
are out of here January 1 and we're out
of debt
would that give you some peace to do a
boat to do both things or do you need to
go right now
um I I think I can hold off yeah how
long have you been in it Kelly how long
have you been in this situation living
situation
um for about
five six years now okay so you've done
it
so so I mean you've you've proven that
for five so that's a long time but also
five years versus four months
um it shows you know what I mean like
that you have the stamina you've been
doing it for five years so you can
hold your breath for for four more
months to get through it would you say
that makes sense
here's what a complete this reader I'm
sorry I was gonna say like my my
conversations I've sat down with single
moms over the years
one of the pervasive feelings that I
hear them explain to me and you can tell
me if I'm wrong but it's just this this
sense of loom looming dread over the
house
this what next I only have this much
time I only have this much margin we've
got so little money there's just this
pervasive air in the house that is heavy
and Laden with angst
and there's something does that sound
familiar
yeah it does okay so what if you focused
on what is the air going to feel like in
our apartment when we move out
and you could move out today like you
said you could cover the bills but you
know as well as I do you'd be covering
them with it would be like playing
twister and you would have one foot on
one corner and another foot on the other
Corner you'd be so spread thin and those
little boys you know what they're gonna
do they're gonna act like little boys
and they're gonna break stuff they're
going to get in trouble they're gonna
run around because they're little boys
that's what they're designed to do
and think about what if you moved into
that apartment in January and you owed
nobody anything
and it gave you that that sounds
wonderful that deeper air that deeper
air to breathe so that might mean you're
gonna miss some little league games or
some soccer games or whatever because
you're gonna work a second job but I
would love to see you put a clock on it
get out of there debt free you've been
there five years it's time to go we we
all know that your mama's ready for you
to go yeah everybody's ready for you to
go yep but let's do it let's let's not
jump out of The Frying Pan into a fire
let's just jump out of The Frying Pan
into ah now it's time how's that sound
right that sounds great I love that I I
mean you can do what you want but that's
what I'd recommend yeah absolutely and
and unless Kelly something drastic
changed in the in the recent you know
few months or weeks that you feel in
danger like right if there's something
there that you're like no I I need to
get out for the the safety and the
health of my family then that's one
thing um but if it's just that you're
almost there you're four months away and
you're just exhausted right can I just
jump the gun go ahead and get out even
though it may stretch all this a little
bit longer I would I would push you stay
in it you've done it for five years you
can continue to do it for four and you
got this Kelly being a single mom it is
um it's a it's a heroic role that you're
in and there's a lot of moms out there
and a lot of dads
um as well but man it's it's really
tough and I really believe though Kelly
you you've done this you've done it so
far I'm like you have four months left
like you can do this so close and the
piece that John's talking about that
happens when oh you actually can do it
and you're not stressed to your limit of
trying to figure out how to pay this
rent when you have no payments leaving
no debt all that extra margin then
you'll be able to live in there pay the
rent and enjoy life
so John we're doing a first ever uh
money and marriage event yes live here
here a full weekend we've never done
this we've done some live streams we've
done some evenings around the country
even before covid
um and then we decided gosh this has
been an event that a lot of people tune
into for the live stream so let's make
it not just an in-person event but a
full weekend experience so the first
ever money and marriage getaway is
October 19th through the 21st and you
and your spouse will come together and
John and I are the main teachers of the
whole weekend we have some special
guests that will be coming in and out
but we're going to spend a whole weekend
together you guys and really dive in and
help you with your family with goals
with your money with your relationships
with your intimacy we're going to touch
on every area of your marriage and give
you the tools to walk away not just
inspired and growing and learning new
things but actually what to do when you
get home and so that's a really big
thing for us we want to give you
tactical things as you continue to grow
and we've talked to people people
that have already you know paid and
they're coming and uh some of our team
has done some calls with them just to
kind of understand who's the audience
and it's so great because I mean all of
them they're like we just want to grow
we just want to learn so if you're one
of those people that's like I just want
to continue to do better in areas of my
life well when it comes to your money
and your marriage this is your weekend
so and by the way people Rachel people
um I know you get this too people reach
out from all over the the country saying
hey could I get an hour with y'all could
I and would you be my coach for my
family for my husband for my wife this
is it yep that's it we'll be you and I
will be there for two and a half
straight days we'll have q and A's we'll
have access we'll have meals together we
will be in this together yep so we'll be
hanging out with you go to
ramseysolutions.com events to get your
tickets to money and marriage October
19th through the 21st
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey show we are
taking your calls America and up next we
have Kate in Philadelphia hey Kate
welcome to the show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
so excited to talk with you
people oh glad you're here Kate how can
we help
um so my husband and I have been debt
free since 2020 we paid off 120 000 of
my student loans and currently thank you
and currently we're kind of on 3B we're
saving we actually own a small home in
the city and we're trying to save for a
larger home like thinking of starting a
family and moving to the suburb
um so recently I guess my question is
more pertaining to a trust fund that we
were recently blessed with um it's one
million dollars and we're trying to
figure out how we use that blessing and
apply it into like our baby steps or if
we save it for our kids future if we're
supposed to use it for our home so we
just love to hear your advice yeah
that's great so you guys are on baby
step 3B you're saving up for
a home we currently have 80 000 saves
outside of our emergency fund we make
about 185 a year 185 a year that's
awesome so before this million dollars
showed up yeah what house is we all
looking at
and then and then we're
now and so once you turn 30 is when
you're able to draw from it for per
major purchases like a house or a car
yeah because I my my tendency right out
of the gate is going to make us get a
million dollar house by any means well
and that should be like hey we're
looking at 250 or 300 000 houses
we got a million dollars let's look at
two million dollar houses right so it
can get out of whack really quick so
that's what I was asking that question
but y'all have known about this for a
while
yeah and our first thought was almost to
ignore it like it didn't exist because
we were like okay let's just keep going
with our plan because I was still I mean
we both drive me up cars like 2005
Toyota Camry and like have a really
small row home in Philly and we're
totally okay like living this way we
like love our life but I'm just curious
about how kind of how much better of a
home we could get and maybe not have to
move again like kind of
um in a quicker amount of time yeah
where did the trust come from Kate
um my very generous and hard-working
father-in-law okay okay since your
father-in-law's that's great and where
is where is the money
I know it's in a trust but it's managed
by yeah it's a managed like in a mutual
fund to a mutual fund okay yeah with the
management group that they use perfect
and so you're you're making money on
that because it's in the market correct
yeah it's so it's growing which is
um yeah which is awesome
so yeah Kate I mean
yeah it's one of those things that you
know you guys as you you and your
husband and you've done this well
already I think there's like this
dignity piece to you all to know that
hey regardless of this million dollars
or not we're gonna be okay we're gonna
we're gonna say we've saved 80 y'all
saved 80 000 for debt free you're
working towards a home
um and so being in that mindset I think
is really important just for you and
your husband uh for longevity right and
it doesn't sound like you guys obviously
are fishing for
Monday or that is trust fund you know
dropped you're like finally we get to go
buy the Yachts that we've won you know
you know it's not this
um air about you
but I think that's the encouraging piece
though is that you and your husband
y'all are okay right regardless of this
money or not so then I think from there
since that's established
to be able to say okay out of this
million dollars what how how much could
we how much would we have to take out of
this trust
to get the kind of how so like what
you're saying maybe could last us a
little bit longer than just the starter
home we were looking at so for you guys
in Philadelphia have you priced anything
that you know you have your starter home
that you guys were saving for and then
you have this trust now you live in a
home now that's uh it's probably worth
like 320 something okay so like 260 on
it we bought it
um shortly after like 2020 we saved a
bunch of money paid off the end of my
student loans and then saved for our
down payment and then got this house
okay um how's the house now yeah it's
small are you do you guys have kids
okay so would you were you guys looking
to move were you wanting to move before
this trust well you guys I guess already
knew about the trust but I'm just I'm
just wondering if you guys in our
timeline so we like we kind of we want
to probably start a family in the next
year or so so looking to maybe have our
house in the next year or so okay but we
could be very patient and aren't trying
to like jump like the next house or
anything by any means sure totally
totally
um let's let's reverse engineer this
if your father-in-law was alive today
what would what would he want to spend
money on oh he is okay
um he is okay um I thought he passed
away and left his money with him and we
are meeting with him next week to like
talk about it to be more
like because I've always
said because I manage
there but I'm like a spreadsheet person
so like so like I when I found out about
it really wanted to know more about how
we could apply it to things that I
didn't want to kind of jump in and be
like okay how can we so it's been you
know we've been married two years now
okay you've been very respectful about
it
my my impulse is
since he's still alive this makes us a
little more awkward but he didn't put
any restrictions on it he didn't put any
other than 30 right he didn't put any
right to be used for house or for med
school or anything like that he just
said when you turn 30 here's a million
dollars
great and so part of me
says what do we think would be his dream
wishes that he would want us to have a
paid for house to start our life and our
family with because if so let's pull out
300 000 of that let's sell our house or
400 000 let's buy a 500 000 house or a
600 000 not a crazy house and in the
Philadelphia area and let's honor him by
being a good Steward of this money and
let's put the rest of it we've already
got the college fund taken care of right
for our kids or what whatever that thing
is with him being here my hesitancy to
go ask him
is you invite him to become a co-stewer
of the money and it's real easy for him
to say hey this this is my money that I
gave you and you all need to be spending
it on X Y and Z and that stipulation
doesn't exist now and so I'd hesitate to
to I don't know yeah into the world but
you could okay you and your husband sit
down and yeah with John sang I think
having a house that's paid I think
living a life without debts and then
being able to change your lives and your
kids lives and all of this using this
money as a tool to do that is a very
honorable thing and so I do Wonder yeah
if you guys say if you and your husband
agree yeah let's pull out 300 of this or
400 of this uh we're gonna leave some of
it in the market because we're not we
don't need it right now but once we have
a kid you know we're gonna pull some of
that out to start a fund like you kind
of have a little bit of a game plan and
you and your husband agree and shake
hands this is what we want to do as our
family and then I think it would be a
and I don't know what your father-in-law
is like but I do think it's a kind
gesture just to be like hey I'm not
asking you but we are so grateful for
this and we're so excited about the next
step and we are excited to say that you
know we're going to take some of this
and we're going to buy a house debt free
and we were going to use some for
college you know what I mean like kind
of tell them your plan just for I would
think if I'm up here and I do something
like that and your kids are responsible
mature and they come back and like well
here's what I'm doing to multiply it's
incredible and to be wise about it do
you know what I mean like there's
something honoring about that if y'all
want to I don't think you have to but um
no and he's like they're both just that
my parents are my parent-in-laws are
just like the sweetest people ever and
they would have the best conversation
and I'm sure that they would be very
respectful that I I guess that would
make me feel better about it because I
think my inkling is like I would like to
almost just have a paid for house and
like start that way but uh I would be
very anxious about like just pulling
that amount definitely the dialect let
me let me say let me say it this way and
this this is probably worth the a can of
beans right but
if I gave my son who was 30 a million
dollars and he had just been married and
they'd been busting their butt and
they'd paid off their student loans and
they had put some money away for a house
and they were talking about starting a
family
and my son came and sat down with me
over I'm gonna get all choked up geez
Louise and he came and sat down over
coffee with me it was old man and he
said Hey Dad I just bought a house with
cash
and I just create put it as what I could
in a long-term savings account which I
for for college so for our two kids
college is covered and that's because of
your generosity and now I can spend my
life not catching up but I could spend
my life creating trusts for my kids that
would be a million dollars thank you I
would weep if my son used that money in
that way to use it as a springboard into
him malt like you said multiplying for
his kids yep and so I I love the idea of
you getting a house a reasonable house
paying it off starting your whole life
with with no debt man that just sounds
amazing it's amazing so great Kate's uh
you guys are wise kind people so um I'm
excited for you thanks for the call this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
so student loans have been in the news
often a lot recently because payments
start back next month you guys interest
is kicked in and people are feeling the
toll and uh there's a article John and I
thought it was a really interesting one
Austin our producer pulled it but
talking about how student loan debt
takes a toll on a vulnerable on
vulnerable populations mental health and
it tells a story of Melanie she's 38 now
but she wanted to be a university
theater Professor so she went got her
PhD and she was just rock and rolling
but then the Great Depression hits in
the late 2000s and she couldn't find
work and so by 2012 her undergrad and
master's degree loans totaled 81 000
with 900 payments a month and so she
briefly was on food stamps depleting her
savings she was sharing a one room
apartment and so all this was going so
then it leads in the article starts
talking about out
the anxiety and the shame that starts
getting wrapped around people that have
this amount of debt they're feeling this
and you know we look at this the loan
debt average is 37 000 per borrower in
America today
and so that's where we're at and what's
fascinating is now science is coming out
and saying and studies are now showing
that it it that your money your debt
levels do have a direct effect on your
mental health yeah and
let's just call a spade a spade here
this this person is it's kind of a case
study that leads into a broader
conversation about mental health and
student loan debt but this student did
got a PhD in
um performance studies one to be a
university professor
so is that wise right is that wise
probably not probably not the white
that's an 80 000 degree but also had a
very clear Direction in mind and here's
what she says and what she says is
actually very true
students are told an untrue narrative if
you work hard in school you'll be able
to pay back your loans if you take out
these loans and get this PhD get this
Masters get this degree and whatever
you will be able to get a job that pays
them back
and that's not true now I do have
colleagues across the country like in
history departments and English
departments that will tell their
incoming students especially PhD
students you will not get a job as a
university professor
just so you know there will be four
openings next year across America yeah
and there's a lot of Stanford and
Harvard grads it won't be you right they
do they're being as candid as they can
honest yeah but these students keep
showing up and they keep showing up
but the narrative globally is if you
just go borrow this money and get
through college you'll be great and
you're gonna be okay you're gonna be
okay and then you increasingly
talk to marginalized populations who
have
um not been told in history like this is
a path and now they're being told this
is the only path go go go go go and they
don't have parents that went to college
and so they don't know how to navigate
this system and so they're sitting in
front of the student loan counselor take
signing their life away
because they just want to do what's
right and I'm just going to follow this
plan and now man the Journal of
addictive behaviors in April 2023
followed 331 college graduates which is
a small study but it's an important
start and they linked high debt levels
with problematic drinking anxiety and
depression especially among the most
economically insecure graduates and
let's let's be honest this makes sense
yeah your brain's gonna sound the
anxiety alarms if you're not safe and if
you owe a whole bunch of money and you
can't pay your bills you're not safe
right but I found one in 14 participants
within the group another study found one
in 14 participants in a group of a
couple thousand uh loan Borrowers
reported having suicidal thoughts that
they attributed to being trapped I can't
get out of this my best option is just
to cash out
this stuff is not just a political
football to be thrown back and forth
student loan debt is crushing young men
and women it's crushing adults who went
back to school and it is really
devastating people's mental and
emotional health their relational Health
this is for Real yep it's for real and
it's scary
um
if you were wondering if this is you
like you were starting to feel that
Panic that burnout feeling that's
chronically stressed feeling that
anxious feeling
um we do have an anxiety test
um it's not diagnostic by any stretch of
the imagination you take this test and
it's not going to tell you you have
anxiety what it is going to tell you is
hey here's the areas in your life that
you should pay attention to Rachel and I
took this test if you're interested
ramseysolutions.com
anxiety test but
um you you took the test and I took it
too and it's very instructive very
instructive it's really good yeah so the
the areas of the test it's on is
connection Freedom mindfulness health
and healing belief and reality and
uh these are the parts of your new book
how to build anxious life that comes out
October 3rd and so yeah you can go
online at ramseysolutions.com slash
anxiety test anxiety tests and you can
take it for free so what did you say we
just did it well it's the results
there's a you get you get all the areas
right and that it okay so let's go
through them so mine connection was
yellow because I was kind of shocked by
I feel like I'm very connected with
people I think you communicate a lot
your body but you probably don't have a
lot of people that you can be completely
open with I do though that's my thing I
got my four people yes I got my four
people three couple I was like I was
like we genuinely I'm like I feel very
no not by a lot though I mean I I have a
lot of friends sure but there's like
those four that know every everything so
God bless them so but but apparently I'm
yellow okay and I'm gonna trust it all
right I'm gonna trust it because I can
also think glass glass half full a lot
about life so anyway so it says your
score your body it might be nudging you
to get your attention in this area so
that's yellow my other yellow score was
mindfulness and mindfulness is about two
words curiosity and awareness okay do
you go to judgment real quick okay or or
do you win very Ted lasso ask when
Winston leaves towels on the floor do
you say
oh my gosh Winston why did you leave or
do you think what must have happened in
his day yeah
that's how he like something must be
going on because he knows I care about
this and one of those your body goes to
war and one of those your body goes to
empathy and let's support this thing see
I feel like I'm very empathize all right
this is obviously not very selfish
I yeah apparently not I mean I don't
know
I don't know I I maybe maybe it is I
mean I I can't be more black and white
in thought no do tell oh my gosh all
right so here's this is my well hold on
the rest are green hold on let me gosh
you're a very non-anxious person my
reality is green my freedom is green and
my health and healing are green okay
yeah so you see a counselor you don't
owe anybody any money
yeah you're a board member at a super
successful company yeah of course those
things are going to be great oh my gosh
you take care of yourself you've been
working out with Winston y'all are
getting that yeah if we do what we are
working out yeah six weeks in mine so
I'm in the middle of a book tour I'm
traveling all over I'm running so this
says change oh absolutely oh I can't
wait about yours stressful John so but
please so uh Freedom Rachel's here
mine actually started flashing at me
um but here's how here's the first
indicator okay so
um I've had a struggle over the last few
years with my daughter she was five and
six and now she's seven
um her tiny little body identified me as
not a threat I don't yell in my house I
don't hit my kids or anything like that
but as a that guy's got a lot of turmoil
in his chest I've done a lot of hard
counseling over the last few years and
for the last six months my I'm like a
jungle gym my daughter won't get off of
me she wants to hug all the time she
wants to piggyback rides all the time
and it has been transformative in my
house in the past couple of weeks
the old no dad and she'll run away and
I'll say can I have a hug and she'll
just duck and move and run out the other
room
and even the other morning I'm just be
honest I was just crying on the way to
work I was like my own daughter won't
hug me then I took this quiz and I have
read for mine mindfulness yellow for
choosing reality yellow for connection
yellow for choosing freedom and if I'm
honest and I really dig in it's right
I'm in a wild season at work and I tend
to isolate myself and there's
frustrations anytime you launch
something big like a book there's
frustrations and I have to wait on
another department to do a thing so I
don't have the freedom to yeah and I'm
looking at this and I thought huh
my daughter she's feeling it she felt it
not wow and that's what I'm bringing
into the house and so I need to lean
into these areas so that my body can not
all the stress is going to go away but
my body knows okay you're back in the
driver's seat of your own life yes even
though things are stochastic you're
driving that's right I can turn the
alarms off now that's right that's right
and it's just the awareness of it and
that's the thing is I'm like yeah you
think maybe you're aware on things but
you're not so go to rooms and
solutions.com anxiety test see how
anxious you are are you more freedom
rachel-esque or stressful job I think
you need some connection and some
mindfulness jeez Louise judgment here
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
comes from Proverbs 12 11 those who work
their land will have abundant food but
those who chase fantasies have no sense
wow
fantasy sports players that was four
years Proverbs all the guys doing their
board season fantasy sports unbelievable
fantasy sports we're grown men use other
real grown men as imaginary action
figures to play imaginary games
do you do fantasy football oh
no you know what I do there's a drum
roll please I go outside and I just like
go fishing or play with my kids or like
talk to my wife like you can do all of
that and play Fantasy Football
but just you know that right think of
this people probably say that about like
guitars and they're like John yeah okay
fine but go outside think about think
about fantasy football I don't really
even understand it you know Winston
really doesn't do it because it's not
real it's a fantasy where other grown
men are sitting on their couches
pretending they're other grown men look
at the points I got I'm I'm coach of
really it's like Zelda except with real
guys
yeah I don't understand it not even a
little bit tell us how you feel about
fantasy football start a softball league
and go play go do something go jogging
it is so interesting that this is what
we're getting off topic but with sports
here's my thing I enjoy sports right I
grew up in the South College Football
Texas I love them yeah I can't wait I
can't wait for the fall like all of us
but I now draw the line if your attitude
or your emotions change
because of a win or a loss of a game
significantly oh mine do I'm done oh
mine do I have to be careful no yeah
I know listen fantasy football people
listen it's embarrassing I'm ashamed of
it
I would that's what I would you yell at
Fantasy Football people yeah here's the
thing I'm like an 18 year old ruins your
day that's the real thing I get
frustrated with is because you are
pretending
when I go to a sporting event a college
sporting event in adults are wearing
jerseys with the name of children on the
back of them teenagers and they're
screaming at teenagers from the field I
know and they're 19. that's what we do
at our house we scream at the TV do you
have does Winston have shirts of college
men on his jersey
no he doesn't okay good actually to be
as like into sports as Winston was he's
not like like we don't have like ESP
like I have friends here and they have
ESPN all the time and stuff like he's
not a big like sports Watcher yeah it's
more just the environment but but yeah
we I know people and like their whole
mood will change because their team
loses
now if you had money on the game which I
don't support but like I get that like
that sucks but a bunch of teenagers
didn't come through for me this weekend
no it's ridiculous I know all right and
then our quote thank you Proverbs for
taking us on that uh good enough never
is Debbie Fields
way to go Debbie right it's great all
right uh going to the phones to close
out the show today is Caroline and
Manchester hey Caroline welcome to the
show
Michael absolutely how can we help
so my grandpa has offered to help me a
little bit by paying for things like gas
and groceries so I accepted his help for
a little while but then I started to
feel very guilty because I wasn't
actually supporting myself 100 percent
so my question is because now I'm
rethinking that decision once he was
insulted by my not using his money
because he's just trying to be uh
generous
so I'm rethinking that decision so I'm
just wondering what do you think about
accepting this kind of small support
from a family member okay uh how old are
you Caroline
I'm 20. you're 20 years old okay and
what's your current you know living
situation are you in school are you
living on your own
yep I'm in um I was in school for two
years and I'm just taking a gap year
okay this year okay great and are you
renting
um a place do you have a house
I'm actually living with my employers
from their pastors and they've offered
me a room in their house okay and and
where do you work
um at the church
at the church okay are they paying you
yeah
they are paying me yeah they're paying
you a livable wage
it's 18 an hour 40 hours a week
okay
yep
so with free rent and with um an 18 an
hour job 40 hours a week you're not able
to make your bills
well I am so that's my question is is it
wrong if I accept his help knowing that
I could to support myself financially
well I think it I think it changes from
he's not giving you help he's just
blessing you with money every month
if you tell him I need your help with
tuition or I need help with my housing
because I'm in college that's one thing
if your granddad just like sending you
checks because he loves you that's
another thing
but if you're telling him a third thing
is hey Grandpa I need your help I need
your help I need your help and he's
worried about you well now we're getting
into some dishonesty so I don't think
he's sending you money for help as much
as he likes blessing his granddaughter
with some cash and
you're um you're making do with your the
situation you've chosen right now so I
mean I don't where does your where does
your guilt come from
I think it's just because
um
I feel like I could just support myself
financially
so
yeah the fact that I'm accepting outside
help just makes me feel like I'm I am
lying
yeah and did he get offended when you
said you don't need the money anymore
okay so that's weird to me well and
that's that makes me think it's not he's
not trying to
all right
I mean if you feel guilty about this do
what's best by you
um I think there's you're feeling guilty
about something that your granddad may
not intend
yep because what you could do Caroline
on one end of the spectrum I mean really
like which I'm saying it's like you know
if you have a Granddad that just has a
lot of money you know put an account and
save for a house right that's right
that's what I was gonna say it's just
say you know hey Grandpa like where I am
financially I'm okay uh he's not like
concerned about your living situation
and he's wanting to you know tell you
Carolyn you need to go
do something else and here's the money
you need to put yourself in a better
situation at all he's not concerned or
with for you is he
yes I would just say to tell him hey
Grandpa I'm you know this is this is
what I'm doing right now and I feel and
I want to practice the diligence of
knowing that I can stand on my own two
feet and this is feeling good for me I'm
20 years old and I want to just know I
can do it but I really appreciate your
generosity and so what I want to do is
take your money I'm going to put it in
an account and I'm not going to touch it
except for major purchases so when I
need to replace my car uh for a down
payment maybe on a future home maybe
it's that you know your your living
situation in six months Caroline you may
say gosh I would love to move out and
have my own place and maybe you can take
some of that to help with a little bit
of rent at the beginning until you can
cash flow it you know what I mean like
give you can give it a purpose without
feeling like you're lying and that
you're very honest with him and open
with him that that's what you're going
to do is you're going to let it be in an
account in an account and you'll use it
for major purchases later in life
because that is a gift and that's
wonderful but if he's all weird about
that that's what kind of well strange to
me
I'm thinking I'm trying to put myself in
his shoes I can't but I can put myself
in a Dad's shoes
if my daughter told me hey Dad I just
turned 18 and dropped out of college for
a year or 20 I'd drop in a college for a
year and I'm going to live in a room in
this couple's house
that sounds incredibly temporary to me
and if you told me no doubt I'm making
all my bills I would think for this
weird second that you've created this
little pocket out of reality you're
right you're making your bills but
reality is coming soon rent and electric
and water bills are coming soon food
bills are coming soon and so I can
imagine he's concerned about what
happens when this thing ends and this
does end sooner than you think it does
whether they have a kid whether they
start getting weird whether they just
want their space back or whatever so I
do think it's very very wise to begin
planning very intentionally for where
you're going to live after this
okay so I I don't have any problem and
you can do what Rachel said I wouldn't
even bother telling him unless he asks
and he says what are you doing with all
that money I'm sending you I'm saving up
to get my own place he'll probably smile
from ear to ear and then back again
um but you can sit down and tell them
here's what I'm gonna do with this money
from this point forward but I think you
need to start planning for a new living
Arrangement ASAP that's a great great
idea thanks Caroline for the call thanks
to all the guys in the booth for a
wonderful show thank you John for
another great hour and thank you America
for listening this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]